[Music]
pedro castillo is not officially winner
of peru's run of election but paloma
duarte is among those
already celebrated
[Music]
this campaign has shown the most
vulnerable people the poorest the
forgotten
now they are the protagonists and it is
important that a rural teacher
from a rural school becomes president in
such an unfair country like peru
with 98 percent of the votes counted
pedro castillo
is ahead of keiko fujimori by more than
100 000 votes
the overseas and rural vote will define
the election
the ballots have to physically get to
the capital and it is likely many
will be contested castillo is set to win
the crucial rural vote
consolidating his victory with little
left to count on monday keko fujimori
did not concede instead she said there
were indications of planned
and systematic fraud
a series of irregularities have been
occurring and we are worried
we think it's important to show this and
call on other people to help us know
if there are more irregularities as it
has been revealing these past days
international and transparency monitors
have been observing the electoral
process
they say the run of election developed
without any major
incidents
right now there is no indication or the
possibility of fraud
not one fraud is a systematic and
general intention to ignore the will of
the people and there is
no way that is happening
keiko fujimori may not be able to turn
around castillo's lead
the race was marked by a campaign that
polarized the nation
the daughter of the autocratic former
leader alberto fujimori
may lose the presidency for the third
time but until all the votes are counted
both parties are set to defend
the support they've got mariana sanchez
al jazeera lima peru